ja und hier ist das plenum wieder gut
gefüllt und die bereits ernannten
minister haben auch schon einmal platz
genommen auf der regierungsbank zwar
noch nicht alle jetzt sehen was wir
gerade nicht aber horst seehofer hat
sich gerade eben da schon im gesetz wo
er demnächst sitzen dann geht auch eine
frau spazierte da gar nichts zu suchen
hat nämlich katrin göring eckardt geht
dadurch den rhein
ich habe da da sehen wir es gerade
angela merkel hat wir wollten noch etwas
wir wollen noch etwas anders sagen wer
auch hier waren heute morgen nämlich
nicht auf der regierungsbank sondern auf
der besuchertribüne wir haben sie eben
auch noch mal kurz in dem
zusammenschnitt gesehen es waren nämlich
auch die mutter von angela merkel das
stimmt ja herlind kasner 89 jahre saß
neben ihrem schwiegersohn
beziehungsweise dessen sohn dem sohn von
noch ehemann joachim sauer von angela
merkel der aus erster ehe ein kind hat
und schaute da wirklich aufmerksam und
sehr geduldig dem prozedere zu ihr
können von hier aus von mir das ist
jetzt das leider nicht nicht sehen wie
wir auf der besuchertribüne sitzt weil
wir sozusagen direkt unter der
besuchertribüne platziert sind dafür
haben wir einen prima blick in den saal
hinein und können sehen dass jetzt in
der tat sich eine hinsetzen auch auf der
regierungsbank platz genommen wird und
wolfgang schäuble wird die vereidigung
der minister vor leben und auch die
bullen diese zog dann wieder eröffnen
er hat nämlich gerade einmal darum
gebeten dass alle platz nehmen genau
jetzt kommt der letzte akt des heutigen
tages hier an dieser stelle
so darf nicht die unterbrochene sitzung
wieder und rufe den tagesordnungspunkt 3
auf bekanntgabe der bildung der
bundesregierung
der herr bundespräsident hat mir hierzu
mit schreiben vom heutigen tage
mitgeteilt gemäß artikel 64 absatz 1 des
grundgesetzes für die bundesrepublik
deutschland habe ich heute auf vorschlag
der frau bundeskanzlerin ernannt
jan olaf scholz zum bundesminister der
finanzen herrn horst seehofer zum
bundesminister des innern für bau und
heimatverein heiko maas zum
bundesminister des auswärtigen herrn
peter altmaier zum bundesminister für
wirtschaft und energie
frau dr katharina bereit zur
bundesministerin der justiz und für
verbraucherschutz herrn hubertus heil
zum bundesminister für arbeit und
soziales frau doktor ursula von der
leyen zur bundesministerin der
verteidigung frau julia klöckner zur
bundesministerin für ernährung und
landwirtschaft frau dr franziska giffey
zur bundesministerin für familie
senioren frauen und jugend herren hier
entspannt zum bundesminister für
gesundheit herrn andreas scheuer zum
bundesminister für verkehr und digitale
infrastruktur frau svenja schulze zur
bundesministerin für umwelt naturschutz
und nukleare sicherheit frau anja
karliczek zur bundesministerin für
bildung und forschung herrn dr gerd
müller zum bundesminister für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung sowie herrn dr helge braun
zum bundesminister für besondere
aufgaben
jetzt hoffe ich auf den
tagesordnungspunkt 4 eidesleistung der
bundesministerin und bundesminister nach
artikel 64 absatz 2 des grundgesetzes
leisten die bundesministerinnen und
bundesminister bei der amtsübernahme vor
dem deutschen bundestag den in artikel
56 des grundgesetzes vorgesehenen 1
die eidesformel lautete
ich schwöre dass ich meine kraft dem
wohle des deutschen volkes widmen seinen
nutzen mehren schaden von ihm wenden das
grundgesetz und die gesetze des bundes
wahren und verteidigen meine pflichten
gewissenhaft erfüllen und gerechtigkeit
gegen jedermann üben werde ich werde nun
die bundesministerin und bundesminister
in der reihenfolge der ministerien zu
mir zum verteidigung zum vereinigungs
es heißt tatsächlich verteidigungsmittel
phone und zu diesem mikrofon werde ich
die bundesministerin und bundesminister
in der rangfolge der ministerien bitten
die leistung des eides erfolg mit den
worten ich schwöre es so wahr mir gott
helfe oder ich schwöre ist
dass man das verstehen ich rufe zunächst
auf herrn bundesminister der finanzen
olaf scholz
ich schwöre es herrn bundesminister des
innern für bau und heimat aus seehofer
ich schwöre es so wahr mir gott helfe
herr bundesminister des auswärtigen
heiko maas ich schwöre es so wahr mir
gott helfe
herr bundesminister für wirtschaft und
energie peter altmaier
ich schwöre es so wahr mir gott frau
herr bundesminister nein die bundes mit
frau bundesministerin der justiz und für
verbraucherschutz dr katharina bahn
schwere herr bundesminister für arbeit
und soziales hubertus ein präsident ich
schwöre so wahr mir gott helfe
frau bundesminister der verteidigung dr
ursula von der leyen
herr präsident ich schwöre es so wahr
mir gott helfe
frau bundesministerin für ernährung und
landwirtschaft julia klöckner herr
präsident ich schwöre es so wahr mir
gott helfe
frau bundesministerin für familie
senioren frauen und jugend dr franziska
gefällt ich schwöre es so wahr mir gott
helfe
herr bundesminister für gesundheit jens
spahn
herr präsident ich schwöre es so wahr
mir gott helfe
herr bundesminister für verkehr und
digitale infrastruktur andreas scheuer
herr präsident ich schwöre es so wahr
mir gott helfe
frau bundesministerin für umwelt
naturschutz und nukleare sicherheit
svenja schulze präsident ich schwöre es
frau bundesministerin für bildung und
forschung anja karliczek herr präsident
ich schwöre es so wahr mir gott helfe
herr bundesminister für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung der gerd
müller herr präsident ich schwöre es so
wahr mir gott helfe
herr bundesminister für besondere
aufgaben dr helge braun
herr präsident ich schwöre es so wahr
mir gott helfe
die kolleginnen und kollegen die
mitglieder der bundesregierung haben den
nach artikel 64 absatz 2 des
grundgesetzes vorgeschriebene neid vor
dem deutschen bundestag geleistet ich
spreche allen mitgliedern der
bundesregierung noch einmal persönlich
und im namen des hauses die besten
wünsche für die übernommenen aufgaben
aus wir sind damit am schluss der
heutigen tagesordnung ich berufe die
nächste sitzung des deutschen bundestags
ein auf morgen donnerstag den 15
märz 2018 9 uhr die sitzung geschlossen
habemus regierung ist es so weit so ist
es und das geht jetzt hier ganz
geschäftsmäßig zu ende und hermann
schluss ist man fast ein bisschen
verblüfft das ist so geschäftsmäßig ist
und dass jetzt nicht noch irgendein
freiheitlicher moment stattfindet
wenigstens die nationalhymne vielleicht
für die leute die uns jetzt dreieinhalb
jahre lang regieren sollen
das ist eben eine sachliche eine ganz
nüchterne art und weise wie deutschland
geführt wird und die regierung bildet
jetzt werden denn die minister in die
ministerien gehen und dort eben auch die
amtsübergabe mehr oder weniger
zelebrieren zumindest wahrscheinlich
blumen und wer weiß vielleicht auch ein
orangensaft oder ein wasser immerhin es
gab ja so ein paar besonderheiten ja in
diesem heutigen tag es gab ein paar
störungen das hat man auch öfter mal so
das transparent oben und es gab einige
ganz nette versprecher jetzt ebenfalls
von dem verteidigungs mit der
vereidigung sneak großen das war's
verteidigungsminister die
verteidigungsministerin in der tat
es gab auch einige stimmen zu wenig für
die bundeskanzlerin bei ihrer wahl das
wird im laufe der zeit dann auch in
vergessenheit geraten aber heute war es
doch ein dämpfer und zeigt ein bisschen
so einen kleinen nachhall der mühen
unter denen diese koalition aus
unionsparteien und spd wieder zusammen
gekommen ist und man wird sehen ob das
auf das regierungshandeln einen schatten
wirft in den nächsten wochen und monaten
morgen ist jedenfalls geht es gleich
wieder los mit der verlängerung von
sechs bundeswehr einsetzen um 9 uhr bis
9 uhr 45 tagesordnungspunkt 5
stabilisierung des iraks und dann munter
weiter afghanistan und folgende
da ist der alltag dann gleich wieder da
und er wird ja auch heute nachmittag
schon stattfinden um 17 uhr erste
kabinettssitzung mit allen
neu vereidigten bundesministern auch
dann wird ja auch schon wirklich sofort
losgelegt werden oder was heißt ja
sofort das ist ja fast übertrieben zu
sagen nach dieser langen zeit des
wartens und der bundespräsident der hat
bei der ernennung der minister ja
eigentlich noch mal ziemlich deutlich in
die richtung gibt zeigt wo es hingehen
soll und und den dem kabinett ziemlich
klar in die ziemlich gleich was mir doch
nicht geblieben
das fand ich auch erstaunlich fand das
hat war eine sehr gute rede die frank
walter steinmeier gehalten hat und einen
satz ist mir in erinnerung geblieben
eine bewährungsprobe für die demokratie
hat er gesagt und das ist auch ein
gefühl das man haben kann wenn man in
diesem neuen bundestag hineinschaut dem
es wirklich rauer zugeht als in der
vergangenen legislaturperiode dass wir
innenpolitisch aber auch außenpolitisch
auch das hat steinmeier ja angesprochen
in zeiten stehen in denen man nicht so
weiß wie es weiter gehen und tatsächlich
eine kluge und umsichtige und
handlungsfähige regierung braucht er hat
den drohenden handelsstreit mit den
amerikanern angesprochen aber es gibt
natürlich auch noch viele andere ecken
der welt in denen kein friede herrscht
und in denen man nicht genau abschätzen
kann was die zukunft bringt ja er hat
auch gesagt dass in der tat der umgang
im parlament zu beachten ist und dass es
auch um anstand und respekt geht bei der
politischen debatte dass natürliches
immer andere politische meinungen geben
soll und muss und das ist auch absolut
wichtig ist dass ausdiskutieren aber der
anstand oder so waren sind im antrag und
respekt insbesondere eben gerade in
diesem haus aus dem wir heute berichtet
das stimmt und da hat sich der ton auch
sehr geändert was vor allen dingen am
einzug da fdp fraktion liegt die immer
wieder versucht auch durch gezielte
provokationen herauszufinden wie weit
sie gehen kann ohne sich einen
ordnungsruf des präsidenten einzuhandeln
heute war ein vorfall da ging es zu weit
als fdp-abgeordnete um seine stimmkarte
und seinen abstimmungsergebnis in der
wahlkabine fotografiert hat was gegen
die geschäftsordnung des bundestages
beim vollzug einer geheimen wahl
verstoßen hat
da gab es dann sofort eine sanktion da
ging der bundespräsident hat aber auch
noch mal gesagt also eins ist aber auch
richtig diese bundesregierung hat genau
wie alle anderen ein vertrauens kredit
verdient auch wenn das alte große
koalition ist es ist eben nicht mehr die
alte es sind neue gesichter sind neue
projekte sind neue vorhaben also auch da
gibt es bitte etwas zu bedenken und
nicht die 100 tage die tatsächlich die
opposition hat ja gesagt wir wollen wir
wollen diese 100 tage also zumindest
haben das haben dass alle außer der afb
gesagt wenn ich jetzt richtig im kopf
habe wir wollen das durchaus zugestehen
oder meint mein steinmeier mit frauen
vertrauens kredit noch etwas an
wer meint glaube ich mehr damit und man
muss ja sagen ich glaube noch nie ist
eine bundesregierung so sehr auch das
kind eines bundespräsidenten gewesen wie
diese denn es war steinmeier der sich
nach dem scheitern der jamaika
verhandlung zwischen unions parteien fdp
und grünen wirklich bis an die grenze
des möglichen glaube ich mit seinen
ermahnungen dafür eingesetzt hat dass
ein weiterer versuch einer
regierungsbildung mit der spd
unternommen werden muss und die spd hat
sich daher am anfang sehr schwergetan
und insofern richtet sich seine worte
wahrscheinlich auch an die
sozialdemokraten auch an diejenigen es
gab ja ein mitgliederentscheid bei der
spd an das drittel der mitglieder das
sich gegen die neuauflage der großen
koalition gewarnt hat und wir haben ja
jetzt ein halbes jahr geschäftsführende
regierung hinter unseren viele haben
vielleicht das empfinden glaubt ihr
eigentlich dass ganz gut gegangen war
eigentlich ganz gut gelaufen
keine große keine großen schäden aber
eben auch keine großen handlungen und
das wirklich so egal wie man blitz
vertrag bewertet jetzt ist hier gerade
gab es gerade kurz schwarz bilder wir
sind noch da denn es tut sich durchaus
noch was hier im plenum
es werden auch selbst geschossen es wird
sich gegenseitig noch glück würden
studie klöckner empfängt hier gerade
gratulation glückwünsche dass sie alle
hier vgv die wir auch schon hier im
phoenix-interview gesehen werde jetzt
ins kanzleramt gibt es ja hier unten
gerade gewissen herrn baader ist der
auch parlamentarischer staatssekretär
wird also den ganzen tag ist jedoch auch
so ein bisschen vorfreude zu spüren
gewesen zumindest derjenigen die jetzt
in ämter kommen und die jetzt dastehen
die gratulanten vor horst seehofer die
jetzt tatsächlich ein neues büro
beziehen
für horst seehofer ist das jetzt auch
mal wieder ein absoluter einstellt als
er hätte ja sonst immer auf der anderen
seite des präsidiums gesetze in den
letzten jahren als ministerpräsident
jetzt ist er wieder zurück auf der
regierungsbank
dies war vorne in der ersten reihe mit
einem ministerium was seinesgleichen
sucht das stimmt und trotzdem ist ihm
der abschied von münchen nicht gleich
gefallen hat er ja auch einige bittere
kommentare abgegeben in den letzten
wochen
und er muss jetzt tatsächlich auch das
ist für ihn auch eine neue
herausforderung das innenministerium in
zeiten in denen die bedrohungslage
in jeder hinsicht gestiegen ist in
deutschland in denen die folgen des
flüchtlings thema weiter zu behandeln
sind in denen jetzt noch zusätzliche
aufgaben bauen und heimat bei hat weiß
ja noch keiner so genau was sich
dahinter verbirgt keiner kommen sehen
richtig da wird er viel stehvermögen
lange arbeitszeiten und noch fanta sie
brauchen und einzeller um das zu
bewältigen
gerade das innenministerium ist ja schon
so ein riesenhaus eigentlich gewesen
vorher geleitet von thomas de maizière
der viele verwaltungserfahrung hatte
jetzt haben wir wieder mehr so ein homo
politicus ist ein ort eine der seltenen
fälle in denen der amtsinhaber keine
juristische ausbildung hatte dieses
ministerium führt das hat in deutschland
eigentlich glaube ich vorher nur ein
einziges mal gegeben sonst ist es so der
ungeschriebene kommandos justiz ohnehin
aber auch innenministerium eigentlich
einen juristen brauchen als hausherren
da ist die grünen-vorsitzende annalena
baerbock die sich jetzt darauf
einstellen dass die kleinste
oppositionspartei zu führen in diesem
parlament
ja denn auch mit der wahl der ernennung
und vereidigung der regierung ist denn
jetzt ja schließlich auch das zementiert
wie hier diese machtverhältnisse im
parlament sind wir haben vor uns noch
mal ausgedruckt dem guten überblick der
sitzverteilung im deutschen bundestag
und da ist eben der blaue der blaue
block der afd
ziemlich klar und man die fest dann eben
auch nicht ganz klein
die fdp und wirklich als kleinste
oppositionspartei die grünen ja die
grünen
das stimmt und ich glaube das system
auch noch nicht so richtig klar geworden
die waren ja schon auf dem halben weg
selber ein paar plätze auf diese
regierungsbank zu besetzen und waren
sehr hoch gestimmt nach der
bundestagswahl weil sie mit einem
schlechteren abschneiden noch
schlechteren abschneiden gerechnet
hatten und jetzt wird sich eben zeigen
dass bei vier oppositionsparteien warf
dem fdp linkspartei und grüne die
konkurrenz groß ist und auch das
verständnis wie man die bundesregierung
kritisieren soll ganz unterschiedlich
ist also
alle werden sich da erst in ihre rolle
finden müssen und tatsächlich wird die
ard das privileg haben als größte
oppositionspartei immer als erste zu
antworten auf regierungserklärung oder
stellungnahmen der minister auch das
wird neu sein und sie besetzen den
haushaltsausschuss ihm vorsetzt genau
das ist halt das recht dass der
oppositionspartei der kosten automatisch
quasi auch zufällt sie haben ja schon
darüber dass sie sagt uns ja schon zum
frühen zeitpunkt das jetzt der erste der
erste große schritt sein muss
tatsächlich ein haushalt in trockene
tücher zu wickeln
es gibt ja ein entwurf noch aus der
vergangenen legislaturperiode
warum steht das noch so ein bisschen mit
fragezeichen dass das tatsächlich vor
der sommerpause passieren also
eigentlich ist es einfach weil
tatsächlich die letzte große koalition
ein entwurf hinterlassen hat es haben
aber in vielen ressorts die amtsinhaber
gewechselt und natürlich haben sich die
prioritäten verschoben durch den
koalitions wird das heißt es wird noch
mal wirklich auch ein bisschen
nachverhandelt alles aufmachen wieder
neu bewerten
mit neuen kennzahlen versehen wieder zu
binden und das heißt es muss also das
wird dieses baukindergeld geben
beispielsweise das muss dann mit dem
finanzminister verhandelt werden jetzt
wie das eingesetzt wird welche
kostenrahmen und viele andere posten
auch und das wurde nicht schon im rahmen
der koalitionsvereinbarung sozusagen
schon ein bisschen eingepreist oder wird
da wird er jetzt wirklich noch mal so
hart gerungen hinter die groben eckdaten
sicherlich aber wir haben gerade vorhin
gesehen dass sich die
wirtschaftsprognose eines wirtschafts
erhöht hatten
danach werden sich dann auch die
haushaltszahlen verschieben können also
das muss alles noch einmal nachgerechnet
werden und der amtsinhaber im
finanzministerium ist olaf scholz
der wird sich damit erstmal vertraut
machen müssen jetzt grüßt horst seehofer
als vor dem start sexuellen ministerium
ja so langsam so langsam lichtet sich
jetzt hier ein und alles
alle gehen in ihrem ministerium oder
wohin auch immer genau das nur frau von
der leyen kann einfach weiter arbeiten
jetzt noch zwei stunden bevor sie zur
ersten kabinettssitzung musste sich für
sie und evelyn nichts ändere und herr
müller
denn das auch in einem für ihn ändert
sich eine auslandsreise wird die zeit zu
knapp bis um 17 uhr erwartet um die
beschaffungs problem mit der bundeswehr
zu lösen dass frau von der leyen
ordentlich hinbekommen nicht ganz an
ihre trotz aller ihrer energie
vielleicht sollten wir noch einen blick
darauf werfen was die spd hat ja
sozusagen in diese
koalitionsverhandlungen etwas was man
als sollbruchstelle verstehen könnte
hineingebracht also sozusagen wir wollen
mal so eine halbzeit bilanz ziehen also
als wäre das ein fußballspiel diese
diese dieser regierungszeit und nach der
hälfte schauen wir mal ob wir uns
irgendwie neu positionieren müssen oder
was auch immer wie lesen sie das ich
glaube tatsächlich dass war ein mittel
um die unzufriedenen dazu zu bewegen
zähneknirschen doch zuzustimmen indem
man ihnen sagt also wir werden halt eine
art zwischenbilanz machen evaluierung
oder wie immer man das nennen mit
modernen politik begriffen
ich glaube aber praktisch wird es ohne
bedeutung sein es war in der vergangenen
legislaturperiode schon so dass der
größte teil des pensums was im
koalitionsvertrag stand abgearbeitet war
nach zwei jahren dann kam nämlich zwei
jahren mit viele landtagswahl nun wenig
politischen fenstern in denen man
wirklich handeln konnte so ähnlich wird
das jetzt auch sein und ich glaube um
die koalition dann zu verlassen muss man
immer noch einen rotierenden und
aktuellen grund finden der sich
verkaufen lässt und er die mehrheit im
land überzeugt dass es wahnsinnig schwer
ja und dann auch noch zum schluss bevor
wir uns dann hier aus dem im plenarsaal
verabschieden herr leithäuser wird denn
was ist ihre prognose wird denn die
bundeskanzlerin die ganze zeit
durchstehen ist ich weiß vorhersagen mit
der zukunft ganz besonders schwierig
also in der tat
ich glaube tatsächlich sie wird länger
bleiben als die hälfte ich bin auch
überzeugt sie wird in zwei jahren
nochmal antreten um parteivorsitzende
der cdu zu werden und sie würzen
im letzten jahr eine entscheidung
treffen also 2020
und damit sagen wird johannes leithäuser
vielen dank danken wir hier zusammen
gemeinsam diese tage diese zeit
übersteht und erhard scherfer ist dafür